robbing now this is unbelievable I want
to give you a follow-up from last week
yeah I'll let a high-pitch tell you
how'd you do on your driving test you
passed yes I can't believe you passed
the driving test what Julie well I went
with him oh yeah yeah what's the update
well so first of all he picks me up from
my place in the morning write to me with
a permit with nobody in the car with so
he gets to my house first thing he does
he gets out of the car he goes some
[ __ ] guy hit the front of my car on
the expressway somebody so he hit
somebody well he claims this guy crossed
over into his Lane and hit the front of
his car this was before his driving test
oh my god he was in an accident now I
get in his car Howard first thing I see
this [ __ ] guy put cop light in his
car what what do you mean the thing you
put on top of the car except it's on the
inside it's on the inside of his car
right by the front windshield I go what
is this box and he goes it's my police
light oh my god I go turn it on I
thought it'd be like fake-looking it
looks like a real [ __ ] cop car but
what are you doing with that Eric we're
gonna do yeah tell them why you have the
cop light sir because it is traffic on
the Belt Parkway or so cuts in front of
me I'll put it on so people move out of
their way out of my way he's gonna get
arrested so Eric you have nowhere to be
in a hurry like where do you have to be
you don't have a job so what if you're
in traffic just sit there like everyone
else like what could be so important
that you'd have to turn on your police
lights you do that what two times a year
exactly yeah
and if you're late don't worry about it
we'll wait for ya so he takes the test
he passes the test he drops me back off
at home I get home I gotta long will
this last well didn't last long because
I got a direct message from a guy who's
friends with a firefighter the day that
he dropped me off that Friday later that
night
Eric were you in another car accident
that night well yeah you have did you
hit someone from behind Friday night oh
my god two accidents how did he pass
that test you saw the test I well you
can't write in the car where I am busy
guy when he got out of the car look
shooken up no it was a woman she didn't
look shaken up Eric did really the only
thing you can do to fail is hit
something can't believe he has a license
and he's into two car accidents already
it's bad he has road rage too he does
he's the guy [ __ ] cut him off Eric you
know what I do when someone cuts me off
I laugh I go okay go you're in a rush
I'm not fine I don't need to kill myself
today Ronnie's a [ __ ] maniac Ronnie
like you I think you both share the same
IQ because he goes nuts you're cool
yeah I'm not rush Eric aren't you
concerned that him one day you got into
car accidents but that's not a number
that answer you just gave has nothing to
do with my question
don't worry you'll get what your car fix
has nothing to do the fact that you were
in two car accidents problem solved did
you learn anything from these accidents
yes good what has to be extra careful
right you learned how to take cop lights
off his windshield